yeah welcome to this video yep gain you
[ __ ] give me a vicious their name and
then no it's not a very active account I
don't think I played it before pretty
high rated to form 71 check again I need
to practice the Bogle try to also get
some experience in the lines i'm
recommending in my book I got some
requests and an term and I'll requests
may be the wrong words I'm some queries
some what about the progress of the book
yeah it's coming along quite quite
nicely but check the release release
date for November that is still set by
as women chest the publisher on I'm not
sure that I'm I'm managing to UM to keep
that date it's some simply am quite a
body of work and it's it's my first book
so I'm really lacking experience okay so
um we had this is a very uncommon
uncommon way to play with III and
exchange but I thought maybe I can do
something against the King here but
they're my bishop is a liability he's
threatening night be three here
Brian's I have maybe 95 okay can that
just that just Castle shouldn't be the
end of the world as always a problem
ma'am yeah this was clear yeah came the
check first no Knight e5 was mine was my
idea
so that it probably exchanges now and
have from the idea to play to retreat
the bishop with Darcy six okay I could
even place you five here just not saying
that it is great but it's a possible
move okay but see success is ok I'll
manage to play d5 as well so it's not a
big deal ok the King position here is
there some way to exploit that may be
here intending to maybe sacrifice on 1g3
yard or something similar if you move
the King I always have this tactic maybe
if I if I don't know this is it looks a
bit shaky Bishop takes it's not possible
i am okay let's so let's play for that
can I move the King do too noisy three
and term
maybe I have a form at the appropriate
moment really this looks like there
should be something but I don't see it
okay this isn't a bad wolf okay let's
let's try to play quickly here
it's just a pawn sec to activate the
pieces on time I have nice bishops now
but should we force them the idea I
could have also played the look at age
22 get it back immediately okay it's
going to play before I have Bishop f5 ok
text Abby five isn't big isn't a big
threat really ok I still need to tell
you to get it back sure if one is Sir I
don't understand really my bishop only
for isn't really a bad piece probably
probably would have just taken it ok but
let's see what happens yeah maybe you're
thinking in terms of pawn structure i
still have lots of pawns on the light
square so there might be end game
scenarios where you can get to the pawn
bishop a6 india but snack let some jack
it's a very active position that i have
here and I control the B file however
this may be look ok this is fine this is
fine first first make sure that he
doesn't play Bishop e7 yeah he needed to
to do that problem so what now this one
and now this is a good move threatening
work 8 b 3 checkmate
hmm
I could I could go to the end game but
this is all tied up I could just take
him but I don't I don't really see him
what is playing here to untangle himself
mmm de smoking
I know it isn't wait not check yeah this
is chad move order check
don't tell me i miss i miscounted here
nice going to promote was check out
don't I don't believe it ah what an
idiot I am NOT winning this game is like
aah chak chak time morning check
unbelievable check yeah about everything
was winning i found the only way to not
win it can I ski gotta get this is
breakthrough himself yeah this is
useless I can resign that black reason
why I forgot about his own break Chang I
can and I just need to this is this is
nonsense I just need to play king of 70
or here I can I can still play I can I
can take it or what yeah i can i can
just approach him what the heck was I
thinking I had 40 seconds on the clock I
was just I just kind of just counting
wrong and he is promoting with the check
completely idiotic yeah this is general
really can't check yeah this this is the
easiest way to do it I can maybe take
him play king III okay so I must I must
take and then then approach this is this
is the easiest way what the heck yeah
what I think one problem wasn't just
allowed me to get a completely dominate
decision here this is just terrible for
white I have much more active pieces
here until this year this is leading
straight to disaster here could could
not them already Chang mmm already get
into a clearly better rook endgame maybe
the best move objectively but he's just
so tight up I didn't want to release the
pressure so early and this justjust
blunders into the losing end game which
I managed to lose okay thanks for
watching